le tapis berbères qu'est ce que c'est je
vais choisir cinq chroniqueurs qui vont
monter ici ils vont avoir des sauts des
sceaux de fausses semoule d'accord ou
acier cdapp s'est passé de la semoule
céda semoule et c'est de la fausse rail
armés
[Applaudissements]
et puis ils vont devoir faire le tapis
roulant et remplir avec la seconde ne
mettez pas le tapis sur la tête de ma
mère je ils vont devoir donc mettre de
la semoule dans ce tube et remplir tout
le tube n'est ce pas youssef c'est
exactement ça c'est exactement ça
youssef sur la terre de mahler gervinho
est dans intervilles service est un
terreau tunis
bien sûr s'il n'y arrive pas et si nous
qu'on passait il aura à la piscine
marisa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'accord les voilà donc c'est vrai ça
viendra cinq chroniqueurs d'accord san
chroniqueurs vous partez dit si on y va
ce moule semoule ou pas ce mot je vais
choisir cinq chroniqueurs je vais
choisir les plus sportifs
bien entendu je vais choisir si j'arrive
à remplir tous leurs tubes les chéris
tout le public ira voir à la deux
attention and going to choose mecheria
je vais mettre mes chaussures
[Rires]
i'm going to see you je vais choisir
qu est ce qu a dit line mais je vous
trouve très drôle mais j'ai l'impression
qu'il arrive ça qui est cool mais c'est
de la semoule
benjamin castaldi non mendy attendaient
jeudi les cinq baraques à ça lui fait
prendre les 5 pouces sportif benjamin
castaldi isabelle morini-bosc remet
alors faites attention
cette attention quand vous redescendez
s'accuse graff d'accord n'allez pas vous
blesser bientôt je vais prendre vraiment
mais moi c'est un gag
oui oui c'était vous c'est faux merci
vous allez faire cela allait faire appel
je vais prendre ya un dj c'est quoi ce
garde
je vais prendre je prends les 5 plus
sportifs un bien sûr alors je ne le fais
pas je le fais pas bien si
éventuellement il ya un vrai problème
ah oui tout est au caire quoi bon joker
ok d'accord ok on y va maxime génie du
sportif à l'école maxime est bien plus
vite que vous ne le croyez vous dire
j'ai fait un petit combat avec les dans
la foi et benjamin au moins cinq
secondes à le mettre par terre
il est fort je me dis que tu as ta force
evropa maximum jure que c'est vrai tu
rigole pas je vais pas prendre bernard
montiel je le sens pas c'est gentil
en plus avec le soleil s'ils tombent
dedans larissa a tué prendre
attention au zen quand même qu'on ait
pas de problème non mais c'est vrai de
cloison nasale et enfin bas jean-michel
ce que tu te sens ah oui c'est vrai sur
gens me et sur mon chéri ce cas là je
veux pas que tu bête quand même le beau
gosse de l'émission
si je te perds non mais ça et je n'ai
plus de beau gosse dans cette émission
c'est votre affaire une tête membres aux
states n'arrivait pas attendez vous avez
une tête de ouf
nan mais sans déconner pas détail mes
frères non mais c'est quoi ce qui est
survenu et à combien de cerveau mais
j'adore ça ne va très bien la grosse
tête
merci allez tu va démarrer oui qu'est ce
qui se passe c'est quoi non en fait oui
oui tu prends que tu me font les
organisateurs auraient alors est ce que
je faisais là bas on enchaîne enfin
exactement d'un comprimé sa personne
mais nous on voit que dominateur aussi
on voit que c'est un aliment attends
attends
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur sa carte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
banny
batterie
aulas
ça va bouger vite fait tout cela bien
qu'il ait compris cela
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attendez attendez reconnaît au sahel
coup tu as mal à l'autre sera mal ou
l'autre sens il avala l'enclos
[Musique]
jeholet on pouvait toucher le parti de
parties de matching et 10 c
coucougnettes et son cerveau ça ne sert
à rien on y va doucement plus gildan et
le fragile
attention la faille a fait pas ne fais
pas le malin mais pas
[Applaudissements]
ouais
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attendez audrey tautou on arrête tout on
est en direct
il est 19 heures salle exactement s'il
pleut on en est au tiers du tube ce que
je propose c'est que je vais lancer est
né d'une mère m'a tenu trop m'avancer un
chrono de 3 minutes
ainsi au bout de trois minutes ils ont
réussi le défi tout le public ira voir à
la 2 cv non plus on ne triche pas en
parle ou à l'arrêt du mans dans les
annonces du mans n'en lève
[Musique]
en anglais c'est bon fais gaffe à ta
gueule attention va lancer un chrono de
3 bien je dis bien trois minutes je dis
bien pas de jeudi mais pas que là je
n'ai pas 4,5
c'est parti c'est trois minutes au liban
c'est parti vous êtes de la semoule dans
la salle aula dans le canton c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous encourent
non
[Musique]
c'est
colère
[Applaudissements]
je